وينضم الان الينا من غلاف غزه مراسلنا
الياس كرام الياس اهلا بك كيف يبدو المشهد
من الغلاف وايضا ضعنا في صوره مستجدات من
الجانب الاسرائيلي
تفضل ليلى واضح بان الهدوء النسبي يسود
المناطق الشماليه تحديدا هذا الصباح ل
لقطاع غزه تحديدا منطقه جباليا وبيت لاهيه
وبيت حنون هذه المناطق تشهد هدوء في
الساعه الاخيره كذلك هو الحال في مدينه
غزه وان كان هنالك بعض القصف المدفعي
والاشتباكات التي نستطيع ان نحددها ونراها
في منطقه الشجاعيه وفي المناطق الجنوبيه
لمدينه غزه لكن من حيث القصف المدفعي
والغارات الجويه يبدو انها خفت مقارنه على
الاقل ليله في الايام القليله الماضيه حيث
كانت تشهد تلك المناطق قصفا مدفعيا عنيفا
ومتتالي وغارات جويه كبيره لا يعني هذا
بالضروره بان حده المعارك قد خفت لانه كنا
نشهد اياما تكون فيها هنالك تراجع لحده
المعارك ولحده القتال وبعد ذلك تشتد
العمليات مره اخرى وكانها تعيدنا الى
المربع الاول الى او الى الايام الاولى
للعمليه البريه كما كان الحال حقيقه في
جباليا في الايام الاخيره اذا نحن نتحدث
عن هدوء نسبي لكن لا نتحدث عن انتهاء
الحرب ولا عن
انتهاء وواضح بان هذا هو ربما ما يميز نعم
اذا سمحت لي فقط اريد ان اشير الى هذا
الخبر الذي ننقله عن الاذاعه الاسرائيليه
ان الجيش الاسرائيلي عمق ووسع من عملياته
في خان يونس وهناك سبعه الويه هناك سبعه
الويه تنشط تحت الارض
وفوقها تفضل
الياس نعم ب بالفعل ليلى وهذا ما كنت سوف
اتي على ذكره والتطرق اليه عندما نتحدث عن
هدوء نسبي في المناطق الشماليه مقارنه مع
الايام الماضيه هذا يعطينا فكره عن
المرحله الثالثه التي بداها الجيش
الاسرائيلي في المناطق الشماليه لقطاع غزه
او نمط القتال المختلف بمعنى في المناطق
الشماليه ثمه اعاده انتشار وتموضع للقوات
الاسرائيليه وعمليات النوعيه محدده بالهدف
وال الموقع بناء على معلومات استخباراتيه
توفرها شعبه الاستخبارات العسكريه
والاجهزه الامنيه الاخرى وتعمل بموجبها
قوات الجيش الاسرائيلي في داخل هذه
المناطق من اجل الوصول ربما الى معاقل
اخرى لحركه حماس او لانفاق هجوميه او
لفوها اطلاق الصواريخ هذا على صعيد
المنطقه الشماليه في المنطقه الوسطى ثمت
هنالك فرقه للجيش الاسرائيلي بقياده لواء
يفتاح احد اكبر الويه المشاه والمدرعات في
الجيش الاسرائيلي هدف هذا ال اللواء هو
عمليا فصل شمال قطاع غزه عن المنطقه
الجنوبيه وفق ما نعرفه من معلومات عسكريه
ليلى هو ان هذا اللواء يسيطر على المنطقه
ال الوسطى في قطاع غزه تلك المنطقه
الفاصله بين الضواحي الجنوبيه لغزه
والمناطق الشماليه للمخيمات الوسطى او ما
يعرف بالشارع رقم 10 والقوات الاسرائيليه
تسيطر على طول هذا الخط ابتداء من غلاف
غزه والممتد حتى منطقه الساحل في عمق عمق
يتراوح بين كيلومتر الى كومتر ونصف بحسب
تقديرات عسكريه هنالك هذا اللواء اقام
حواجز عسكريه واقام ثكنات عسكريه للجيش
الاسرائيلي وهو ينشط في عمليه ل تامين
عمليه الفصل ما بين المنطقه الشماليه
والمنطقه الجنوبيه ومهمته الرئيسيه هو منع
اي محاوله من جانب الفلسطينيين الذين
هجروا من ديارهم في المناطق الشماليه من
العوده اليها بدون اذن من الجيش
الاسرائيلي وواضح بان هذه القوات تقوم في
عمليه تموضع فقط بمعنى انها لا تنشط
عسكريا في عمليه دهم انما تتخذ كما يبدو
مواقع دفاعيه وهذا ما يفسر هذا اليوم
التقرير الذي اصدره الجيش الاسرائيلي
عندما قال بان هذه القوات احبطت هجوما من
جانب مسلحين فلسطينيين في تلك المنطقه
بمعنى ان هذه القوات ربما تصبح عرضه ايضا
لانها تقف بحاله ثبات ودفاع ربما تتحول
ايضا الى هدف بالنسبه للمقاومه الفلسطينيه
وبالنسبه للخبر الذي اتيت عليه في المنطقه
الجنوبيه واضح بان المنطقه الجنوبيه هي
المنطقه الان التي تشهد الزخم الاكبر من
حيث العمليات العسكريه نحن نعلم بان
الفرقه 98 تعمل هناك مع سبعه الويه من
الجيش الاسرائيلي العمليه العسكريه هناك
ايه تسير ببطء شديد وبحذر شديد لان الجيش
الاسرائيلي يعلم بان هذه المنطقه وفق
التقديرات الاستخباراتيه العسكريه موجود
فيها الاسرى الاسرائيليون المحتجزون في
داخل قطاع غزه لذلك العمليه تسير ببطء
شديد وبحذر وان كان بالامس وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي واف جلان قد اشار الى ان
العمليه سوف تتوسع في منطقه خانيونس لكن
نحن سنرى ما الذي كان يقصده في هذا السياق
لكن الواضح انه منذ اسابيع هذه العمليه
تسير ببطء شديد وبحذر شديد بسبب هذا الامر
اشكرك الياس كرام من غلاف غزه على كل هذه
المعلومات